paio appears headed for confirmation
this week as the country's next
Secretary of State Pompeyo will replace
Rex Tillerson who was fired by President
Trump last month so worsens
controversial tenure is part of the
story of America's shifting foreign
policy that is the subject of a new book
called war on peace the end of diplomacy
and the decline of American influence
journalist Ronan Farrow looks at the
long-term decline of the State
Department and what he calls the growing
militarization of u.s. foreign policy
Ronan Farrow spent several years working
at the State Department including the
office of the Special Representative for
Afghanistan and Pakistan last week The
New Yorker won a Pulitzer Prize for
Pharaohs coverage of Harvey Weinstein
he's a contributing writer at the
magazine Ronan Farrow joins us at the
table
Ronan good morning such a pleasure to be
here guys great to have you here have
you here you write about the decline of
the State Department that it didn't
begin in January 2017 but has been going
on for decades what did you learn
look invariably when you see the
headlines about what's happening at the
State Department now usually using words
like war on the State Department battle
against the State Department gutting of
the State Department it's usually
accompanied by unprecedented and the
fact is it's a new extreme but there are
a lot of precedents we can look at and
draw clear lessons from going back to
the Clinton administration right after
the end of the Cold War we had the
message of it's the economy stupid and a
turn inward and in fact over the course
of the 90s a 30% cut to our diplomacy
and development spending and what
happened then was our embassies around
the world became underfunded we closed a
bunch of outposts around the world and
lost a lot of influence in important
places and we actually shuttered two
government agencies related to
information and arms control clearly in
retrospect as we confront Isis and
rising nuclear powers those were goals
we didn't want to get with that American
vacuum what country is filling that
space sort of a shadowy backstory across
this whole book is that China is nipping
at our heels and filling a lot of these
spaces so don't get as important as what
is happening in today's State Department
don't get distracted from the larger
story that you spent a long time working
on help people who don't exactly know
where and why diplomacy is so important
what is so
and about diplomacy there's two ways in
which this affects our day-to-day lives
one is sort of at the top level right
there was a time in which when the
United States confronted a conflict we
had peacemakers and negotiators and
experts on these really complicated
challenges steering things you look at
us barreling into potential meetings
with North Korea leader to leader right
now at one time we had a unit of experts
that could guide that and embed it in a
long-term strategy and what the experts
were saying now is we no longer have
that we're not welcoming their views
there's a second dimension to this
though guys which is the basic kind of
unglamorous work of diplomats protects
all of us the stamping of passports the
screening of dangerous people before
they get into the country the running of
our embassies and the pulling out of
Americans who are in danger
that's all work that's being diminished
right now well you say in your book that
experience really matters that in
diplomacy persuasion is a weapon of
choice and I think you raised Ronan some
very troubling things about what's
happening in the Trump administration
you said from the very first day that it
really was the transition was a big joke
they were basically told pack your bags
and that even as we see her today there
are so many positions that have not been
filled this is very very concerning even
though this is a vast story in the sense
that it's about a fundamental shift in
how America exists in the world that we
are becoming a nation without expertise
that shoots first and asks questions
later a lot of the time it's told
through the lens of as you suggest these
characters in this ravaged profession
really bravely trying to serve our
country and getting kicked out on mass
as it turns out in the first days of the
administration which is that period
you're talking about there without being
replaced it's interesting you've talked
to all of the living Secretary of
State's on record who were very candid
with you and they all seem to be saying
the same thing which is there's a
variety of levels of candor but look
I'll give colum how was an example he
said we are ripping the guts out of
diplomacy we are mortgaging your future
so George Marshall went from World War
two general to diplomat in this what
you're writing about how much does 9/11
and the fact that the US has been
engaged in live Wars caused this shift
to a more military centric diplomacy and
what are the problems with that it's
hugely significant and I'm careful not
to oversimplify the picture here
the world landscape changed and the rise
of the national security state is partly
a consequence of these inevitable shifts
that you know we didn't necessarily have
control over but what I show is that in
conflict after conflict we actually have
gone farther than we needed to in the
direction of military dominance of the
policy process that we have actively
sabotage chances at political
settlements in places like Afghanistan
for instance does politics play a role
nobody campaigns and says I'm gonna have
more interagency groups you know they
say we're gonna defeat Isis yeah I'm
glad you raised that because partly this
is a cultural problem this is about a
group of brave men and women who served
in dangerous places for Less pay than
they could get in the private sector and
yeah there are dusty bureaucrats who you
know punch the clock and you know are
entombed in this bureaucracy and don't
get a lot done but more than that there
are wonderful men and women putting a
lot on the line and they're doing
important work that isn't celebrated
with a ticker tape parade when they come
home and I think that that's exploited
in a really vicious way for political
gain by both parties you also talked
about you had a front row seat working
with Richard Holbrooke who was not the
most popular person you could say that
on the staff but at one point he says to
you have you taken leave of your senses
never good when your boss says that to
you Ronin what had you done part of this
book with this vein popping out yeah I
forget that that's the last stretch of
his life and an incredible career on the
world stage he was a difficult
complicated person this is a really
personal book in a lot of ways it's
Parsloe partly a memoir of my time
seeing these changes firsthand as a
little guy at the bottom of the totem
pole in that administration and
Holbrooke was a great lens through which
to view this problem you know he
brokered peace in Bosnia he understood
how if military might is arrayed behind
diplomats you know no one is saying get
rid of the military downsized the
military people are saying restore the
balance in a more sensible way and he
was a great example of how that can work
if you have a correct balance of power
well tonight some time 100 list
congratulations you're on it I can't
imagine what your life has been like the
last year working on this and your New
Yorker piece my life has been very tired
very grateful for all the sources that
spoke in those stories about Weinstein
and also in this book there's a lot of
whistleblowers who put a lot on the line
to tell this story
great reporter congratulations to you
thanks guys great to be here the name of
the book is called war on peace it goes
on sale today wherever you like to buy
your books lots of places to do that